gustavo petro juró su cargo como
presidente de colombia frente a una
multitud de ciudadanos que se hicieron
presentes en la plaza de bolívar de
bogotá por primera vez en la historia
del país humanitario izquierda llega al
palacio de nariño saludamos entonces a
néstor rosanía director ejecutivo del
centro de estudios en seguridad y paz en
colombia' néstor gracias por su tiempo
buena mañana del lunes gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa
muchas gracias para ti y para todos los
alimentos néstor hablemos de los temas
más destacados del discurso de gustavo
petro no ya empezó entonces a esbozar un
poco lo que sería su plan de gobierno
aquí en estos o 4 años iniciales creo
que hay tres temas muy grandes primero
la lucha contra las drogas y comprometer
a los eeuu en esa lucha contra las
drogas no sólo en términos de la
producción que la tiene colombia y perú
sino en el términos del consumo y eso es
un tema que cambia la política que
históricamente ha tenido el país en
contra de las drogas
lo segundo hablo de la paz total cómo
hacer esa paz con todos los grupos
armados no sólo con el ln sino con todos
los grupos de disidencia tanto de pharr
como de paramilitares y lo tercero
también el tema del medio ambiente como
un eje crucial el tema medioambiental
siempre había decidido algo accesorio
ahora lo ponen sobre la mesa como un
tema vital en la política pública del
gobierno pero desarrollamos entonces
estos tres puntos
principales y centrales de discurso del
nuevo presidente gustavo petro este tema
de las drogas dijo que era una política
de digamos para casada y fallida la
lucha contra la droga entonces en este
tema o sea qué piensa hacer el gobierno
de petro para cambiar esta política
digamos que también la la tiene colombia
actualmente no lo primero es hablar de
una corresponsabilidad esto lo intenta
hacer santos pero un fallo en la idea y
la corresponsabilidad dice hay tres
actores fundamentales el país productor
los países de tránsito y el país
consumidor colombia y perú son los
primeros productores de cocaína a nivel
mundial los centroamericanos son todos
los de tránsito y eeuu y europa son los
mayores consumidores la carga hoy en
términos criminales caen sobre los
productores y los tránsitos pero el
productor siempre maneja esto como un
tema de salud pública lo que está
diciendo gustado petro o todos en la
cama o todos en el suelo quiere decir
tiene que haber una corresponsabilidad
de todos los actores néstor también
hablo una tan anhelada además por el
pueblo colombiano que tanto ha sufrido
por la guerra estamos hablando de la paz
total que tan difícil sería realmente
sentarse con todos los actores armados o
estos grupos al margen de la ley armados
que que hacen vida aquí en colombia
sobre todo también por supuesto por el
narcotráfico no cómo hacer para
realmente tener esta estapas total
gustavo petro a tener dos modelos de
negociación uno de proceso de paz con el
ejército liberación con nacional con el
ln donde va a seguir desde donde lo dejó
juan manuel santos y el segundo se llama
sometimiento a la justicia quiere decir
que los grupos como el clan del golfo y
todas estas nuevas organizaciones de las
disidencias de las farc y los
paramilitares se van a [__] esa un
sometimiento a la justicia no es un
proceso de paz como tal entonces les dan
unos beneficios penales para que estén
menos en la cárcel y también puedan
digamos de alguna forma entregar sus
activos eso es lo que va a manejar ahora
bien lo que la historia nos ha
demostrado es que no todos se van a
vincular a eso porque el precio de la
cocaína a nivel internacional sigue muy
alto puede ser que se entreguen los
mandos pero las bases van a seguir en el
negocio cambio climático néstor también
es muy enfocado digamos el gobierno del
nuevo presidente gustavo petro unas
energías limpias unas energías
renovables pues digamos un modelo
económico y político no sostenible con
el medio ambiente que tan difícil es
lograrlo que tan fácil también o difícil
sería esta transición y sobre todo en
estos cuatro años porque recordemos que
el presidente también planteó un
programa bastante amplio no para cuatro
años de gobierno como lograrlo va a ser
el más difícil yo creo porque en la en
el tema ambiental tiene toda una
producción internacional que el país ya
está comprometido en términos de
petróleo y carbón pero también la selva
amazónica es uno de los puntos más
difíciles porque hay una tala ilegal
gigante por el tema del narcotráfico
también hay una tala ilegal de madera y
lo más difícil no hay presencia del
estado del estado nunca ha llegado a
esas zonas donde realmente están todos
digamos toda la biodiversidad del país
ahí va a tener un reto como llevar el
estado a sus lugares más lejanos que tan
difícil es llevar el estado a estos
lugares no es supremamente difícil
colombia se dice que tiene una muy
pequeño y un territorio muy grande
porque las instituciones no han podido
llegar cuando llega al estado es en
versión de fuerzas militares y policías
para atacar a los grupos armados pero no
están mucho tiempo ahí regresa
nuevamente a los cascos urbanos y esas
zonas quedan completamente vacías hace
espacio ha sido poder es donde llegan
todos los grupos armados ilegales un
solo ejemplo la frontera con venezuela
tenemos rastreados más de 17 grupos
armados peleándose un pequeño segmento
de la frontera por todas las rutas del
narcotráfico la minería y la tala ilegal
que hay allí también habló el presidente
gustavo petro de la corrupción dijo que
iba a poner a disposición a todos los
organismos de inteligencia del estado
para digamos para seguir a estos
corruptos a las personas que han evadido
también fiscalmente y que han hecho daño
al país en materia económica como la
tiene en temas de acabar con la
corrupción el presidente de colombiano
gustavo petro esta va a ser una lucha
tan grande como la lucha contra las
drogas porque la corrupción es algo que
hace parte de la cultura política del
país el tema de la contratación el tema
de los porcentajes en los contratos la
capacidad burocrática de cada de poner
puestos dentro del listado ha sido un
tema histórico que lleva más de 70 años
es una cultura política muy nefasta que
tenemos como colombianos entonces tiene
que casi que empezar a transformar el
modelo de político para que realmente
pueda atacar a la corrupción hoy
colombia es uno de los países más
corruptos de suramérica sin lugar a
dudas y eso también se en en qué implica
esto que esos recursos nunca llegan a
las zonas más alejadas más pobres porque
la clase política tradicional se la roba
como no llega ese dinero finalmente esas
comunidades esas comunidades quedan
finalmente a disposición de los grupos
armados ilegales
néstor también habladas en un punto muy
importante y donde operan precisamente
esos grupos armados ilegales y es la
frontera entre colombia y venezuela
recordemos que estas relaciones digamos
diplomáticas y comerciales han estado
pues suspendidas por el gobierno del
presidente iván duque luego que el
gobierno eduque el gobierno anterior
reconoció el agua yo como presidente de
venezuela en el discurso no hubo ninguna
alusión a estas relaciones
internacionales bilaterales tan
importantes y que también la gente
estaba como a la espera de que realmente
va con estas nuevas relaciones entre el
gobierno colombiano y el gobierno
venezolano que podemos también sacar de
allí fue fue bien especial que no
hiciera ningún tipo de mención la gente
también estaba esperando cuál va a ser
su política internacional con los
vecinos se dirigió más a eeuu por el
tema de las drogas por el tema de las
energías limpias pero no hablo de
venezuela venezuela era el segundo socio
comercial después de estados unidos para
colombia el segundo mercado más grande
de una frontera económica muy activa
entonces está en ceros hay un tema de
crisis humanitaria muy grande la
cantidad de refugiados colombia nunca
había recibido un refugiado por producto
de conflictos internos para nosotros
todos estos nuevos recibir refugiados
entonces hay que crear una política
pública un plan fronteras frente al tema
del crimen organizado pero también sobre
el tema del drama humanitario y la
reactivación económica la frontera pues
vamos a ver su canciller a álvaro leyva
es el que va a empezar en estos días a
dar los primeros tips de cómo hacer esa
reactivación fronteriza hablamos también
por supuesto de la vicepresidenta la
vicepresidenta francia márquez que
además además de ocupar este cargo como
vicepresidenta va a tener a su cargo
este un ministerio de igualdad como se
va a desarrollar también que se espera
de la nueva vicepresidenta colombiana y
también de este ministerio que va a ser
nuevo para colombia es una
transformación y la transformación viene
desde la posición de ayer yo tuve la
oportunidad de cubrirlo y lo que veíamos
era una posición atípica en el sentido
que la posesión presidencial en colombia
era la digamos una posición de élites
las élites colombianas eran las que
estaban ayer hay perdón tradicionalmente
ayer lo que vimos fue la cantidad de
grupos étnicos de indígenas de
campesinos que estaban en la plaza de
bolívar francia marc que representa una
de las zonas más afectadas por la
violencia que es el cauca vimos muchas
delegaciones de esa zona del país
entonces lo que empezamos a ver fue una
nueva dinámica una nueva colombia y unos
nuevos actores que aparecen en la
política pública y que siempre habían
estado relegados